die pakete sind da ich bin mega
aufgelegt ich frage mich echt was
stalinist auf social media wurde ich so
lange mit werbung für mir unbekannte
fashion shops bombardiert bis ich
tatsächlich gestellt habe doch was taugt
die ware wirklich hätte ich gesagt habe
ich damit ist nun dass andere
umgerechnet
angeblich beste qualität stark reduziert
doch wo sitzen die shops definitiv aus
china bekomme ich auf diesen seiten
wirklich nachhaltige designerkleidung
zum kleinen preis war okay ist eine
komplette produktion
die haben da was vergessen bei vier
dieser shops habe ich bestellt und am
ende dieses videos erfahrt ihr wlan mich
gewartet habe wie viele ich wirklich
bekommen habe und was ihr tun könnt
damit es euch nicht so geht wie mir
[Musik]
zum beispiel dieser legenden finde ich
echt gut auf den fotos sieht ja richtig
schick aus die bewertungen sind auch
echt gut
komisch ist dass die gar kein impressum
haben seit ich letztens online ein paar
t-shirts gekauft habt denken insta
facebook und co ich brauche noch mehr
neue klamotten ich bekomme ganz viel
werbung für rudi shops und solche
designerläden
dir zum beispiel die schreiben sie sind
eine nachhaltige designer boutique es
gibt 50 prozent rabatt und das scheinen
auch recht viele leute interessiert zu
sein auf den ersten blick sieht der shop
total glaubwürdig aus sehr professionell
eigentlich gibt es nichts dran zu
meckern nachhaltige produktion
umweltfreundliche materialien und kurze
transportwege haben für uns oberste
priorität
faire löhne und sozialverträgliche
bedingungen für unsere mitarbeiter sind
in unseren unternehmensgrundsätzen
verankert die gründerinnen anna sophie
und markus entdecken ihre liebe zur mode
und fashion während des studiums auf
flohmärkten catwalks fashion shows und
in secondhandläden ich würde schon echt
mal interessieren was da kommt ein super
nachhaltiger shop offenbar mit total
engagierten gründer innen aber ohne
impressum ohne hinweis darauf wo die
boutique eigentlich sitzt ich will
wissen ob etwas kommt und wenn ja was
ich bestelle mir den kadi gern aus der
social werbung und vage das experiment
thorsten behrens von der watchers
internet beobachtet shops wie diesen
genau denn neben den vielen guten online
shops gibt es leider auch ein paar
schwarze schafe das sind einmal die fake
shops das sind wirklich die shops bei
denen man bestellt bezahlt und nichts
bekommen und auch nichts mehr hört und
dann gibt's halt die billiganbieter drop
super die irgendwo aus asien versenden
und meistens billigware versenden beim
dropshipping verkauft ein online händler
ware die er selbst gar nicht im lager
hat erst nachdem ich das produkt gekauft
habe bestellt der shop ist beim
hersteller oder bei einem großhändler
und der schickt das dann direkt an nicht
der shop übernimmt also nur die
bestellung und abrechnung nicht die
lieferung direkt versand nennt sich das
bestelle ich also bei einem solchen drop
schiffer hat bei einem workshop oder bei
einer wirklich nachhaltigen designer
boutique ich bin gespannt was kommt in
einem anderen job habe ich dieses
schicke casual jacket im britischen stil
bestellt stark reduziert von 113 euro
auf knapp 57 kostet also nur noch die
hälfte es ist der erste shop von dem
eine versandbestätigung kommt fünf tage
nach der bestellung ich war ja skeptisch
ob überhaupt etwas kommt jetzt bin ich
aufgeregt dass die jacke bald geliefert
wird aber dann checke ich am abend noch
mal den versandstatus okay es ist
richtig komisch ich habe heute morgen
die mitteilung bekommen dass dieses teil
hier versandt wurde
und jetzt plötzlich
heißt es konnte nicht zugestellt werden
und ich sollte exportieren aber wenn ich
dann kommt hier das das shipment
gecancelt wurde vom absender das ist
noch in china den vorschlag
auf diese selten wird es sein mit dem
shop kontakt aufzunehmen ist gar nicht
so einfach eine mail adresse finde ich
ganz versteckt unter einem linken
bestellstatus da schreibe ich mir fällt
auf auch hier gibt es kein impressum
in einer mail finde ich aber versteckt
eine adresse in miami
okay das ist krass also ich habe jetzt
gerade mal die interesse bei google maps
eingegeben und da kann man bei street
view schauen schließe aussieht dann
kommt einfach hier ein barbershop
und wo setzt das nachhaltige fashion
outlet von anna sophie und markus da
hatte ich den kadi gern bestellt auch
hier gibt es kein impressum die
betreiber verschleiern auch wer die
domain angemeldet hat aber mittlerweile
hat hier das paket anscheinend seinen
weg aufgenommen von nue in china zum
internationalen flughafen hansson
mit dem flugzeug nach lüttich in belgien
dann über saulheim in rheinland-pfalz
und über ginsheim gustavsburg nach mainz
elf tage nach meiner bestellung trudelt
das erste paket 1 ein paar tage später
noch zwei weitere 43 pakete bekommen und
ehrlich gesagt ist das schon mehr als
ich gedacht hätte also ich hatte gedacht
wir warten hier noch viel länger und
vielleicht kommt am ende 1 oder so es
kann sein dass der wirklich drin ist
also das kann passieren das kann aber
auch sein dass du es echt gut aussieht
also lasst uns das auspacken definitiv
aus hat der zoll drauf geschaut
immerhin ist auch
der stoff der ist ja wie diesen dienst
stoff hätte ich gesagt habe ich dann mit
bisschen was anderen gerechnet sieht
schick aus
ok nächstes paket
sieht halt so glänzt sich irgendwie aus
wie so ein trick rohstoff irgendwann
glaube
man schwitzt da und ich glaube das
müsste jetzt der kaa gent sein
flauschig
wir sind wissen zu klein
das ist aber eigentlich größe m
[Musik]
die haben da was vergessen
ich fühlte die haben
das noch die tasche vergessen ob das
jetzt hier nachhaltig ist
keine ahnung aber ist das vielleicht
trotzdem noch in der qualität dass es
auch in der einkaufsstraße bei einer
modekette hängen könnte das will ich
wissen deshalb nehme ich meinen
angeblich nachhaltigen cardigan mit so
einem nachhaltigen modelabel in mainz
ja ich habe sie dabei
wir mal gespannt was gebracht hat
designerin alice stegmaier hat lange für
die riesen der modeindustrie gearbeitet
2020 hat sie dann ihr eigenes label
gegründet
nachhaltig fair und bio sind ihre stücke
was sie wohl zum einen cardigan sagt
und
wenn ich mir das jetzt ansehe
hier ist nirgends ein fashion label also
das heißt hier haben das ist eine wäsche
lebe dein care label wie sich das nennt
das ist zum beispiel in europa ist das
pflicht das muss in jedem artikel rein
muss drauf woraus besteht das wie ist
die wasch anleitung und votet produziert
deutschland besteht eine textil
kennzeichnungspflicht
was ist das überhaupt
ok also der pulli ist illegal hier
dieser shop könnte abgemahnt werden aber
woraus besteht der cardigan nun auf der
website stand beim material hochwertiger
baumwolle
da steht das ist hochwertige baumwolle
wenn ich hier eine phase also den faden
da rausnehmen
wenn ich das jetzt anzünde müsste das
bei baumwolle oder bei pflanzlichen
fasern also zb
eine gute etc müsste da so ein bisschen
wie verbrannt papier riechen und dann
auch so asche geben ja
weil es ist pflanzlich wenn nicht dann
wenn sich jetzt aber so eine so ein
kügelchen formt und nach plastik licht
dann beißt bescheid dass das pflaster
okay ist superschnell und
dass sie nicht nach
ja keine asche also wenn du hier fließt
das ist so ein knötchen
also baumwolle
nachhaltig scheint das material also
nicht zu sein aber was ist mit den
fehlenden löchern für die taschen kann
man sie vielleicht doch oft wenn hier
das ist eine komplette produktion das
ist eine tasche da hätte eigentlich die
funktion wir sind also ich kann das
nicht auf ein
ja na super dieses teil hat mich knapp
40 euro gekostet ich bezweifle dass es
sich dabei um ein nachhaltiges
designerstück handelt aber das ist jetzt
keine designerware und es ist auch nicht
nachhaltig
was findest du nicht mal bei h&m oder
zara wein auch die haben ihre
richtlinien keine ahnung hast es gleicht
maximal fünf bis zehn euro gekostet
haben statt hochwertiger designer
kleidung also billiger dropshipping
massenware aus fernost ich suche im
internet nach dem produktfoto diski
dance und finde ihn tatsächlich wieder
dj dropshipping einem dienstleister für
jobs shipping händlern hier gibt es den
kollegen ab 8 dollar 97 umgerechnet
knapp acht euro mit versand nach europa
liegen die kosten für jobs schipper um
die 20 euro bei einem verkaufspreis von
knapp 40 euro also circa 20 euro gewinn
für einen händler der außer der social
werbung und dem betreiben der website
wohl kaum kosten hat und was ist mit der
schicken jacke die sich als jeansjacke
herausgestellt hat laut website soll sie
mal 113 euro gekostet haben ich hab sie
für knapp 57 euro gekauft auch da suche
ich nach dem produktfoto und finde es
tatsächlich bei seagate jobs shipping ab
sechs dollar 90 umgerechnet etwa 6 euro
ziehen wie kann das sein ich frage
nochmal designerin alice stegmaier
was ist hier offensichtlich ist es halt
schon attraktiv weil du hast keine
personalkosten dorf keine lagerkosten du
kannst ja auch das ja von zu hause aus
machen aus seinem wohnzimmer und fertig
weil du hast ja das lager nicht bei mir
hat das heißt die bestellung kommt rein
und irgendwo dann in china wird sein
versendet und du hast ja dann damit
nichts mehr zu tun weil wieder touren
also ja aber du willst jetzt das nicht
retournieren das ist das was ich würde
ganz gerne zurück eigentlich
sehr umständlich und kostspielig wichtig
müssen dafür zahlen ja das ist bei allen
drei produkten die ich bekommen habe so
der shop von dem der cardigan kam
schreibt auf seiner seite
rücksendung und kosten sind vom kunden
zu decken und zu bezahlen die adresse
ein industriegebiet im chinesischen eu
wie kann man sich dagegen wehren
anwältin nicole mutschke bekommt jede
woche mindestens eine anfrage von leuten
die auf dubiose shops reingefallen sind
sie kennt meine lage nachdem wie die
situation sich gestellt habe ich gleich
noch das deutsche widerrufsrecht aber
was nützt mir manchmal nicht so viel
wenn ein verkäufer dann in china sitzt
oder daneben die kosten der rücksendung
von mir zu tragen sind so die mischung
macht dann auch dass es sich dann häufig
gar nicht lohnt was die schon
zurückzuschicken und ich dann quasi auf
dem schaden sitzen bleiben die anwältin
hat eine klare haltung es braucht mehr
transparenz bei einem job shopping
das größte problem beim doping sehe ich
eigentlich daran dass man es sich offen
legen muss also spricht dass mir als
käufer gar nicht unbedingt klar ist dass
ich in einen solchen shop bestellen denn
ja wenn man sich das ganze so zu sagen
mal auch praktisch vorstellen dann wird
relativ schnell klar ich bestelle und
meint vertragspartner muss ja dann die
ware erst mal besorgen das heißt es kann
natürlich erst mal dazu führen dass der
vielleicht auch die ware gar nicht
bekommt also sprich wenn es engpässe
gibt dann wird schwierig drei von vier
paketen habe es innerhalb von etwa zwei
wochen bekommen auf 1 vaart ich noch da
kann es dann teilweise sehr sehr lange
dauern bis die ware kommt oft kommt die
dann erst wenn man schon gar nicht mehr
mit rechnet nach drei bis sechs monaten
bei fake shops kommt gar nichts und das
geld ist weg auch das könnte mir bei dem
fehlenden paket passieren übrigens ich
habe den shops auch geschrieben und
gefragt was sie zu den vorwürfen sagen
eine antwort habe ich nicht bekommen nur
der nachhaltige designer shop der ist
jetzt nicht mehr online für alle die
nicht so risikofreudig sind wie ich in
diesem experiment hat torsten berens
tipps wie man sich vor bösen
überraschungen schützen kann drei punkte
auf die man unbedingt achten sollte das
eine ist dass man mal im impressum
schaut ist das irgendwie
plausibel wenn es keins gibt finger weg
und ansonsten naja wenns plausibel ist
muss das immer noch nicht heißen dass es
seriös ist dann sollte man unbedingt
auch noch mal schauen was schreiben
andere über diesen job also die domain
eingeben und dazu erfahrungen oder
probleme oder so was da zu suchen und
schauen was schreiben andere und der
letzte punkt ist die meisten fake shops
haben auf der startseite alle möglichen
zahlungsmittel angegeben mit denen man
bezahlen kann wenn man dann aber am ende
zum bezahlen kommt alles plötzlich nicht
mehr und es ist nur noch die vorkasse
per überweisung steht zur verfügung
spätestens dann sollte man den einkauf
abbrechen habt ihr schon mal erfahrungen
mit dubiosen online-shops gemacht oder
wird euch dafür werbung angezeigt
schreibt dass uns doch mal in die
kommentare würd mich interessieren
[Musik]